Many work all day, others help
outside and inside the home, no matter
what the situation, they take care of their
family and make sure they don't lack for anything.
For me,
I became a father
and discovered what pure love is
on the same day. I also discovered
that I was a superhero. I have two girls,
a 17-year-old girl is
going to university and the routine with
her has changed, it has evolved a lot
in that now  I do almost nothing for them
one of them has to do that very well in
this aspect she knows how to take care of herself very well it
is a different case with my youngest
girl my youngest girl named sara
they were
born with a
genetic condition and that condition has brought
many many problems so my
daily routine
revolves around
how she gets up children to therapy
therapy to every day from monday to
friday i work nights i have been
working nights for 15 years
ca  Yes, from the time I was born, now
I am lucky that the
work company knows my situation, they
understand very well
that the situations
are difficult, that it is a little out of the
ordinary, because why don't I go
there is no other help and I explain myself or
It is normally there is a mother who is in
normal cases but in this case it is a
very different case because there are
no girls do not have that part I have
encountered several challenges
with
being a father you never imagine that
your baby
can do position with
difficulty
and sometimes they are
You have to fight against it because that
's what you are doing every day. It's easy to get
frustrated sometimes because it's
and because the girl
is limited in many things. In this
state, there
aren't enough resources
in schools
for girls like, but the main
problem we've  had away with the
schools is that there are not enough people
in this county the school district there are a
lot of people who judge
I am the type of person who
normally carried  a mango that people thought
there was a time in my life when there were
many looks
and one notices those things what is most
difficult of all this
what is it
is a question that I ask myself almost
every day and that is that the time will pass
the day that I am not well
what will happen to her what I
told the parents you
always have to be involved you
always have to be
there for either a minute or five minutes
or ten hours
you have to share time with the children
she doesn't want to  To say that these men
are more important in the lives of
children, you
have to be
a role model
I describe myself as soaked hard
to be me. I feel
I feel happy because being a father has
given me the opportunity to recalibrate
my water a
few words so  simple
means reported for him it is nothing in
spanish
natalia lanzelotti